[Music]
this episode was proudly made possible
by Subaru
so one of the ways in which I describe
human beings is by saying we are
addicted to the new now what does this
mean addicted to the new it means that
we are addicted to explore the
perimeters of possibility we are
addicted to probe the unknown to gnaw
against the ineffable we are program
neurologically with the chemical
dopamine to reward us for overcoming
limitations and exploring the unknown
this idea this addiction to the new is
responsible for a species that didn't
stay in the caves didn't stay on the
planet and won't stay within the
limitations of biology literally we are
addicted to the new and that is why we
have tried to become the chief agents of
evolution it's the dopamine it's the
dopamine be sure to check out second
chance subaru at revision3.com Subaru
[Music]